my trust is totally gone
amanda hall went to the police to report
the historical sex abuse she'd suffered
but she was then groomed by the officer
who handled her case i was extremely
vulnerable at that time and i just you
know
just
wanted some
care and attention
the detective alan butler lured amanda
into an affair
she realized later he'd preyed on her
vulnerability he was jailed for
misconduct
he
used his position
to groom me
he knew that i had
really severe trust issues
and
after afterwards i would reflect on it
and think of the things that he'd
actually said to me and think how could
you have been
manipulated like that
it's a year since pc wayne cousins used
his police powers to falsely arrest
marketing executive sarah everard
then he raped and murdered her
the cousin's case was extreme and rare
but there are still many officers under
investigation for abusing their police
powers
according to the independent office for
police conduct at the end of january
there were 260 current iopc
investigations
31 involved abuse of powers for sexual
gain
there were 29 sex assault and harassment
allegations and 32 of domestic abuse
by far the biggest at 81 were complaints
over the use of force
the stories that have emerged about the
kind of culture within policing and the
and the number of police officers who
are using their position
uh for sexual gain is
um
that those figures don't particularly
surprise me there needs to be a process
of
reporting that victims can have
confidence in to come forward and there
needs to be you know very very strong
messaging from leadership um that this
will
not be tolerated
officers abusing their powers for sexual
gain is now the biggest corruption issue
the police watchdog has to deal with in
2020 the issue accounted for 60 percent
of all corruption investigations
the 31 current investigations cover half
the forces in england and wales
the metropolitan police has six cases
martin brunt sky news